I, I, uh, I don't know. It's just, uh,
it's it's it's it's episode one 25. And this is what I want to look up though.
This is the thing that made me laugh.
It's been awhile since I've laughed this hard,
bro. So the Toronto Raptors one, congratulations to run a rapper,
Raptors love, uh, Kauai. Very cool.
Um, it was hilarious how he, he,
he won the game and then still would wouldn't wouldn't be excited
until he got to do his free throw because he was fouled at set
Kauai. But then when they won Drake, Drake,
Hey Drake, I love Drake. You, you, you're not on the team.
Okay. You're just not on the team. Now, when you give posts, interviews,
you're on the team, right?
So what the the deal I get he's a major people are like,
why did he even interview him? Do it. He's right. Okay. But dude,
this interview was the best.
[Inaudible] you just got to watch it happen.
The six and six. What does that mean? Six in six. So six, the sixth,
which is Toronto in six games. Right? That's what they want. Okay.
[Inaudible].
Trip to this city now. All now, now,
now what we know right there is he lost all the dads. We don't know. You know,
if you, if you're a dad, you don't know what the he's talking about. Right.
You're just like, okay, well, what does that mean?
Bring it brought a chip to the city. I'm out. Okay.
If my dad was listening to this, you'll be like, what was that?
You get chips when you win. Okay.
[Inaudible].
Oh, I don't want my, I want the chips with the debt.
I don't want my chips. I don't want my chips with the debt. So dude,
that's what he was saying. Okay. I don't know what he means.
Do you know what he means? Getting a chip? Is that money? I don't.
Here we go.
[inaudible].
My favorite thing is to think of Drake being like, here we go,
he's walking through the thing and he's like, here we go.
I see the guys and with all the microphones and everything like that. And I,
I like to imagine he was like, I'm going to do my chips thing.
Like on the way to the game, he was like, if they win,
I'm going to do that chips with the dip thing.
Like he's just with his girl or with some homeys.
And he's just like driving to the game, being driven to the game.
And they're like, yo Drake, just maybe to this may the time where they win.
And they have a one in a while and he'll be like, yup. They're like,
they're going to obviously interview you. And he's like, yeah. And he's like,
what are you going to say? And he's like, I got it all sorted. No worry.
I got it all sorted. Cause you know,
they brought a chip to the city if they went right. And the dudes were like,
Oh yeah. And they don't know, but they're saying yes,
because they're in Drake's camp and you don't say no to Drake. And he was like,
yeah. And they're like, all right, well I'm just going to make,
I'm just going to go on like this D this chips run, you know? Well,
I say how he brought a chip to the city and I'm gonna start talking about DIT.
And they're like, yeah, that's rap. That's dope talk.
And then he came up and did this.
Why Leonard
[inaudible].
You know, what's funny is too. So, so bring them tips.
So bring them FIPSE, dude. You know, what's funny is too.
And I made a meme of it and I made the first one and then people kind of ripped
it all off and. And uh, about the,
I said, hello, welcome, welcome to Applebee's. Can I take your order?
And then he welcome to have [inaudible].
[Inaudible] dude.
It, so it's either he set it up,
but I don't think actually he decided on saying it while he was driving to the,
uh, uh, game.
I think it took him off guard and he was like, they brought a chip to the city.
And since you know, his music is like, so like, you know, in rap,
there's so many metaphors and he's like a pretty hardcore metaphor guy.
And so he was like, he said the chips thing. And then he was like,
I want my chips with the dip. And then there's a little flicker of like, Oh,
I don't know what the, this wasn't the best analogy.
But what I really like about Drake is he doesn't back down. He said,
I don't want my chips plain.
I want my chips with the dip and then further furthered it and said,
so bring them bips,
which was just in credible dude.
I want my chips with the dip. That's all I know. So bring them pips.
Oh my God, dude. I know.
So bring them tips and then
dude. Wow.
Why, why,
why does Kauai look like you just watched seven documentaries in a row?
Always looks like he just watched like S like seven hardcore documentaries where
everyone gets cancer. And he's just like,
there was a meme where he was were, they took a picture of him and he was like,
and everyone was cheering.
Everyone was like excited that they won the championship and his face was just
chilling. And then, and somebody wrote, man,
courageous are already forgot that he won.
But like he's so in his head dude, but dude,
God bless.
[Inaudible] that's all I know. I don't want that.
[inaudible] about what it means. You know what it means?
You can turn your canvas up to the screen and know what it means.
Hockey. You even know what he's saying. What does it mean to you? He's like,
it's not about what it means. What do you mean, dude?
It's not about what it means. He brought a chip to the city dude. Of course.
It's about what it means. He's just so amped. You know,
what's funny is all the fame, all the money, all the.
Like your inner dork will always shine through, you know,
and everybody has some sort of version of their inner dork,
but it always will come out if you're too excited. I don't know what mine is.
Mine is not basketball for sure.
But it's so funny, dude.
I guess a championship is a sh is a chip. I want my chip.
I don't know what it means. People on my app or like chips means championship.
I'm a love Drake dude,
that new song with Chris Brown who beats the out of women. That,
that song it's okay.
Everyone's talking about it's the new Anthem of the summer and it's a K it's K.
Well, my chips with the dips on my chips, I don't want to wear regular chips.
I want them tips with the, imagine all the people like, there's just like, Oh,
the caramel garlic. I don't know. But I got it. You got to have someone,
you gotta have someone to direct your life. Dude.
You gotta have a wife for syrup.
Partner to the city.
Otherwise that's all I know. I don't let you
bring them.
If Jake had a wife at that ride home would be like, what was it? She'd be like,
w w what is it? What is, was the chips with the dip thing a hundred percent?
And he'd be like, what, what do you mean? She would be like, why do,
what is the chips with the dip? And he's explained, you know, like chips,
the dip, the championship, and then the dip. So I,
I went on like, it was like, if chips were that's when you realize, Oh,
I'm an idiot because you have to look at someone's face when you're explaining
it for real wives or partners,
whatever the, maybe you, you know, dudes or whatever. That's good,
but you need to do to keep it real. Keep it a hundred.
That's why I keep it at a hundred. You got, you're not lying, but also,
you know, you could still have a wife and go nuts like Kanye, I guess.